Taka, what is your plan for the rest of your stay in the US?
Tomorrow I will visit one customer in San Jose.
After that meeting, I fly to Phoenix for another meeting.
I will fly back to San Francisco on the following day.
When are you going back to Japan?
I will leave the US on Friday.
Wow, you have a pretty tight schedule!
Every time I come to the US, the schedule is always very tight.
Business trips are very tiring, because we schedule so many meetings.
To cut costs, we are reducing the number of business trips company-wide.
It's the same here.
We're doing many more conference calls now.
Recently, we got an advanced video conference system.
It was very expensive, but it could save a lot of money, compared with travel costs.
Less tiring too!